you
hi this is Andrew and Michael from
cognition team this is a demo of the
prototype of project in a phaser and
this is a time of flight sensor which
can be used in the projection of a door
as well as of the hololens not
generation so what you are seeing right
now is like sensor module in a test case
test prototype case and it's connected
to a PC and the PC will do a local
processing to convert the raw image to
the depth image and then render it into
a 3d point cloud so Michael is basically
the object right now before the depth
camera and you can see the details on
his shirt is very clear and the
stability of the point is very good
and this camera has a much better
quality there are lots of improvements
on the how where and software side and
you can see you can reach to really
close range as well if you put your
finger near the camera and you still get
a very good depth map and then it has a
very wide field of view you can see I'm
also in the picture as well you may
notice that the range here like I'm
disappear because this is an example
mode which only showing the show range
but we can switch to a long range as
well and you can see it's actually
supporting much further and also the
point cloud is really really stable and
we are basically targeting a high
accurate depth camera with low noise and
also this is a very low power
consumption camera as well and
eventually this will be a technology
we're gonna use in hololens which is
trying to help people talking in the
scenario like 3d reconstruction people
tracking and also hand tracking gesture
things like that ok that is about this
demo and if your interesting project
king of azure please look for project in
a for other keyword online and we have a
website have all the information you
probably can viewing a survey and bring
your feedback and keep being tuned like
we'll be there
you